the northern city of talakhan
is surrounded by taliban fighters for
more than one month
its people have withstood waves of
attacks
residents now armed and afghan security
forces
are united in trying to keep fighters
out of the city
i hope i'm not captured we've been
attacked more than 10 times here
we've beaten them and pushed them back
don't lose your morale
the taliban now controls large areas of
rural afghanistan
including more than half of the
country's districts as afghan security
forces
attempt to slow the taliban's momentum
in a nationally televised address
president ghani had a message of
diplomacy
we've articulated a widely supported
program
for a bridge from an all-out war
to adjust and lasting peace to a
political settlement
we do not see a military solution
we firmly believe in a political
solution
ghani the former finance minister and a
former world bank economist
spoke extensively about the economy less
about the war that's ravaging his
country
about a third of the government's
revenue comes through border crossings
it has lost more than 33 million dollars
in the past
month after the taliban seized seven
crossings
the largest is here in spin baldurk
after two weeks
it has just reopened to trade naturally
we are scared because conditions are bad
we are afraid of going into afghanistan
but there is no other way out for us
there are no other jobs for us here in
the border region
two hours away in kandahar city
residents have had enough
there has been fighting and air strikes
on the city's outskirts in the last week
these people were demanding both sides
agree to a ceasefire
[Applause]
the growing insecurity is leading to an
increase in the number of afghans who
are leaving the country
the un says 20 to 30 thousand are
fleeing
every week there are also thousands of
afghans who worked with the u.s
government
who are waiting to hear if they will be
on evacuation flights
in the coming days charlotte ballas al
jazeera kabul